The jogan Experience from an
intelligence perspective how did that
October 7th thing not get detected I
mean doesn't the IDF don't they have
agents embedded in Hamas don't they
don't they have
like the most intense security system
ever and surveillance system ever they
do yeah and it was a massive
intelligence failure and in part it was
a very um it it was a
very I don't want to say sophisticated
sophisticated is the wrong word but in
terms of the planning of this uh if
you're conducting an operation or you're
conducting any intelligence really uh
concerned then the first thing you need
to know you need to worry about is need
to know right so how do you limit
information how do you limit how do you
limit the dissemination of of
information about what you're doing um
and that's just good opsc that's good
operational security Now that's what
they did they displayed
extremely sophisticated I suppose
operational security over this because
you're right there's human sources that
the IDF and and shinb and others in
Israel have within Gaza there's the
communications intercepts signals
intelligence um you know there's just
general surveillance that they're doing
uh of the region in terms of movement of
goods but most of that movement of goods
happens under ground right 300 maybe 300
miles of tunnels in Gaza that they've
built using money by the way using money
that was probably meant for Clean Water
Works and other infrastructure and
improving schools and hospitals um
that's a whole different angle to talk
about but yeah I think the security side
of
things um by doing that by limiting who
knows about the operation and by because
again
there you could legitimately argue the
political leadership of Hamas they had a
sense you know I'm sure at some point
they approved a large scale operation
but the people who who really knew about
this were the uh Islamic revolutionary
guard Corps the irgc which is
is organization with the Iranian regime
and they're kind of the liaison partners
for Hamas and Hezbollah um they manage a
lot of the training issues they funnel a
lot of the money that goes to these
organizations that are Iranian proxies
and so you can count on the fact that a
limited number within the irgc were
aware of the planning and the training
because they did train Hamas operatives
in Iran prior to 7 October so I think
yeah they it was simply a matter of them
saying all
right this element this cell will have
knowledge of this during the course of
training this these guys over here will
know this these people will know this um
and and maybe a handful of people will
understand the full picture and will
understand when we're going to do
this and it's all designed to keep it
away from um from Israeli intelligence
and it was ridiculously successful in
that
regard so you know and and and also you
could argue intelligence is a human
operation so or an Endeavor so you're
going to have failures on occasion you
just don't want them to be this massive
um there were occasional comments about
the inclination of Hamas to do something
bigger no details no specific details um
and Hamas also spent a great deal of
time leading up to this Con I mean years
convincing um the Israeli government
through their words through their
actions or lack of actions that it was a
new day and that what they're looking to
do is create a different dynamic or
relationship with the Israeli government
and so the Israeli government became
complacent and when they became
complacent to some degree over Hamas and
the fact that there hadn't been any
strikes there hadn't been any terrorist
actions for a period of
time then what you saw was then they
kind of turned Inward and people talk
about the political divisions within
Israel and the fact that the government
was in a bit of disarray and there was
it was a little dysfunctional a lot of
arguments going on that in part was
because uh you know they had the not the
luxury but the ability to kind of turn
in on themselves because they didn't
feel necessarily that that ex that
threat outside was as bad as it had been
right and that they thought perhaps it's
diminishing perhaps you know Hamas is
changing its tune and that was a
deliberate attempt by Hamas to lull them
into that state right and so there were
there were a lot of things going on at
the same time but yeah there's no way
around it it's a massive intelligence
failure the most cynical and
conspiratorial take on it is that they
let it happen because this is the best
way to destroy Hamas that they knew it
was going to happen so they allowed it
to take place yeah that's that's pretty
cynical
um yeah I mean if if you can get your
head around that idea that they said
yeah we're going to let Hamas or someh
encourage Hamas to come in and Slaughter
all these women babies children
men um I suppose that's you know if
someone can get there then God bless
them that's that's their right but uh
I'm not buying it um you know I've seen
I've seen intelligence failures before I
know it can happen no matter how many
cameras you've got up no matter how good
your signals intelligence intercepts are
they dumb that down right I'm not
calling anybody on the phone because I
know you're going to pick that up right
I'm not going to talk about this
anywhere I'm going to hand a note to my
cousin you know who runs a you know a
part of a battalion in in Hamas you know
they got whatever two dozen battalions
so but I'm going to keep that
communication as stupid as I can that's
what Al-Qaeda did right and then and
they dumbed it down and it becomes much
more difficult they limit the number of
sources who know about it that limits
your target pool of of assets who can
tell you something um from a human
perspective and you know but again
people are going to I I've seen some
pretty wacky conspiracy theories come
out of this since 7 October right and
you know I'm I I'm not buying that one
yeah the the most conspiratorial was
that uh Netanyahu was kind of on the way
out with the people and that this is uh
the way for him to sort of galvanize
everybody and get support and maintain
power and and then do what he actually
wanted to do go in there and attack
Kamas yeah yeah well it's it's it's one
Theory um but uh when ever have
something this chaotic you're always
going to have a bunch of wacky theories
yeah yeah and and you know I get that um
cuz you have a lot of people who you
know still refuse to believe that you
know Hamas doesn't give a about
Palestinians and again I keep going back
to the same thing which is well take a
look at Gaza you know and you tell me
what Hamas has done for the people of
Gaza because again Palestinian people
aren't lined up 100% behind them you
know in fact there's you know there's
been reports of Looting of Hamas uh
facilities since they've been losing
their grip on on power um the Hamas
leadership structure is enormously
wealthy right they they've stolen
billions of dollars um that was
theoretically intended for Palestinian
improvements can you explain that like
how did they get a hold of the money and
how is the money allocated like say
where's the money coming from when they
get money for the improvements of
Sanitation and education and schools and
all that it comes from it it comes from
a variety of sources look I think the
the EU the European Union is I think the
largest donor still to the Palestinian
uh people and it comes through various
um uh organizations so uh the United
Nations the refugee office uh UNR W um
the US Aid USA ID um and other and some
Nos and well quite a few NOS so money is
donated or allocated by governments and
the US
is us has given billions of dollars um
to through these organizations for the
uh Improvement of uh Palestinian lives
right for and and part of that came out
of the Oslo Accord um the idea being you
know band together um improve the
infrastructure for the Palestinians
create this because that will March
towards more stability and eventually
maybe that allows for a solution find
you know that that will eventually come
about and whether it's a two-state
solution or however it's worked out so
that money Flows
In but since 2007 Hamas controls what
goes it's like it's like when we give
money to uh the Taliban now giving money
to the Taliban in Afghanistan
and we like to pretend like they're
going to use it for good causes we like
to pretend we know where it's going or
how it's being
handled but this money flows into these
various organizations and and Hamas
controls what happens right so one way
or another they get their hands on that
money and they decide what they want to
do with it and for the most part it has
been for the uh for the betterment of
Hamas as an organization in part because
that's what Iran expects them to do and
Iran also provides them with funds um
not the Palestinian people Iran directly
funds
Hamas so over the
years they have the leadership and
particularly the the political
leadership who all basically live
outside the of Gaza they in Doha and in
cter um you know some reports and
they're confirmed by the US Treasury
it's not just the Israelis saying this
you know they're billionaires at this
stage of life and you know one of them's
got a couple of kids who are on
Instagram right and they're flying on
private jets and they're you know they
probably went to the World Cup when it
was in Doha and it's it's it's ludicrous
because billions of dollars that
literally Were Meant to provide clean
water or better schools or whatever and
people just you know continue to shake
their fist and say it's all Israel's
fault how is the money allocated and
where does it go and how does Hamas get
their hands on the money like what what
is what's the expectations when they're
giving this money and how I mean I don't
understand if they know that it's going
to Hamas why are they still sending
money well in part because um
that's that's the purpose of so the US
funds say the US says okay this year
we're giving whatever $400 million uh
through these various Aid organizations
now the aid organizations at some point
on the ground right have to make a
difference right they have to so money
has to go somewhere it has to go to uh
middlemen it has to go to somebody
running a business who's then going to
provide resources whatever that is uh
grain some whatever Transportation
Trucking to move things around Gaza
whatever it is and Hamas um it's like
they it's like a criminal gang right
it's like an extortion racket almost
they they take their cut um they tax uh
the uh resources that are brought in
right um most of those things have to
move most efficient way to move goods
and services through Gaza at this point
because of all the work they've done in
the tunnels is the tunnels so they tax
Goods moving through the
tunnels they make their money right and
and I don't want to I'm not equating
Hamas necessarily to a to a mob but it's
kind of what they've been doing and
so now the money that comes from Iran
that's a different that's that's that's
direct to Hamas that's direct to Hamas
again they take their cut right H it off
but then they spend it because that
they're beholden to Iran they spend it
on what they're supposed to which is you
know more weapons uh more gear uh paying
their their Fighters uh
and
so yeah I just I keep coming back around
to to this notion that you know the
Palestinian people have been getting
screwed you know left and right there's
no doubt about it right and um civilian
casualties are are tragic and
sad but we live in a very pragmatic
world you know hopefully we not I mean
you you can't rule this thing by
feelings and hope and you know
positivity it's not it's Hamas chose a
certain path and they have to be dealt
with right because um if you stop and
allow them to say okay well Hamas is
still there they're still running things
nothing nothing changes doesn't improve
the lives of the Palestinians right
continues to fuel and fund
Terror so okay fine if you feel better
about a cease fire and kicking the can
down the road but you're not don't don't
pretend like you're solving something
you know so so when the money gets
allocated it's like say if there's money
that's being sent to Palestine for clean
water and all who's receiving that
money well it goes it it's funneled
through the organization so like that
money is is is think about it like a
bank account it's deposited with the UN
Refugee office
right they decide they allocate um
because they have essentially vendors
right who are saying okay we're going to
provide whatever penicillin or we're
going to provide hospital beds what so
they they're they're parsing this out to
a variety of vendors both in in uh and
you know there's an an attempt to try to
ensure that it's uh Palestinian
businesses and Hamas also runs
Enterprises over seas right so or sorry
outside of Gaza so they run you know
businesses uh in uh turkey and a variety
of other countries right um
so sometimes that money is going to a
Hamas control business right to then
purchase what theoretically purchase
whatever is necessary
um we shouldn't imagine that
is they're not like Al-Qaeda they're not
sitting in a cave somewhere right
they've been doing this for a while and
um you know it's it's a bit like uh it's
a bit like the Ira Ira started out with
very clear mandate right eventually an
element of it was just about drugs and
and guns and you know money um so you
know I keep coming back around to Hamas
they they realize they got a good thing
going right stability is not going to
keep that gravy Tain running
so